An alternative is to achieve the same effect, but completely oblivious to the
guest operating system, and this is used in VMware ESX server. The idea is to
use content-based sharing. And in order to support that, VM Ware has a data
structure which is a hash table kept in the hypervisor. And this hash table data
structure contains a content hash of the machine
pages. So, for instance, this entry is saying that. For virtual
machine number three. For it's physical page which is at this address
43f8 there is a machine page that hosts this
physical page number of VM3 and that's contained in
machine page number 123b and the content hash that is... If you hash the
contents of this memory page, you get a signature. That signature is the content
hash. That content hash is stored in this data structure. Now let's see how this
data structure is used for doing VM-oblivious page sharing in the ESX Server.
We want to know if there is some page in VM2 which
is content wise the same as this page contained in
VM3. In particular we want to know if this physical page number.;
PPN 2868 of VM 2, which is mapped
to this machine page,1096 is content-wise the same
as this guy. So how do we find that out? What we do is we take the contents of
this machine page 1096 Create a content hash. So that's the content hash
that you're going to generate, a particular algorithm
that the hypervisor is going to run to
create a content hash. So we create a
content hash for this page 1096, that corresponds
to PPN 2868 of VM 2. Now we take this content hash and look through hypervisor's
data structure to see if there is a match between this content hash that
I created for this page and any page currently in the machine memory.
Well we have a match. We have a match between the content hash for this page and
the content hash (no period) Of the page
comtained in VM 3, 43f8, which is mapped to
MPN 123b. So now we've got this match. Can we know that this page and this page
are exactly the same? Well, we cannot. It's
only a hint at this point that this pages
content hash is the same as this because this
content hash for 123b was taken at some point
of time. And we created this data structure to
represent this as a hint frame, which has a
particular content hash. Now, VM3 could have been using
this page actively and modified it, and if it has
modified it, then this content hash that we have
in this data structure may no longer be valid.
And therefore, even though we've got a match, it's
only a hint, not an absolute. It's only a hint.
So once we have a match, then we want to do a full comparison between these
two guys. Make sure that these two guys
are exactly the same, full comparison upon match.